ayudar a los países ahogados por la
deuda externa a afrontar el cambio
climático y reformar el sistema
financiero internacional para que sea
más justo con el sur global son algunos
de los objetivos de la Cumbre que empezó
este jueves en París
decenas de líderes mundiales acuden al
evento a la espera de ver cambios
efectivos
el presidente francés Emmanuel macron
usó su discurso de apertura para pedir
más recursos financieros al sector
privado
ningún país debería tener que elegir
entre reducir la pobreza y proteger el
planeta hay mucha liquidez en este mundo
hay mucho dinero en este mundo no creo
que logremos cambiar el sistema por
completo Aunque sé que es la aspiración
de alguna gente la primera ministra de
Barbados miamotli también es anfitriona
de la Cumbre es una de las mayores
defensoras de la idea de reimaginar el
rol del Banco Mundial y del fondo
monetario internacional frente a la
crisis climática incluyendo la
suspensión de pagos de la deuda cuando
los países empobrecidos sufren
catástrofes climáticas lo que se
requiere de nosotros En este momento es
una transformación absoluta no una
reforma de nuestras instituciones y esta
transformación es necesaria porque a
pesar de que desde 1990 sabíamos que
enfrentábamos el calentamiento global
elegimos no escuchar el consejo de los
científicos
algunas de las ideas planteadas para
recaudar fondos para el clima implican
impuestos adicionales sobre la industria
fósil La Naval y sobre las transacciones
financieras el encuentro pretende ser
una lluvia de ideas antes de citas
económicas y climáticas como el g20 en
India en septiembre o la cop 28 en Dubai
en noviembre